bonjour michel monnier merci de répondre
à nos questions avant d'évoquer
l'assurance chômage
un mot sur l'autre réforme celle des
retraites qui fait également l'actualité
selon un tout récent sondage au doxa
backbone consulting pour france info et
le figaro publié hier
60% des sondés se disent opposés à une
réforme avant 2022
comment expliquer ce chiffre alors que
les retraites représente un énorme poste
de dépense publique près de 15% en 2019
bonjour alors effectivement les
retraités représentaient 14 ou 15% mais
je me prenais rapporte pays des pourquoi
les une majorité se déclarent contre 7,7
formula je pense qu'au sortir de cette
crise sanitaire et de ses conséquences
économiques et sociales
davantage que de continuer à de remettre
en train de remettre sur les rails le
train des diverses réformes celle de
l'assurance chômage et celle des scènes
des retraites
les conditions sont réunies pour posée
d'une façon plus générale la question de
ce que doit être le modèle de protection
sociale et vouloir engager alors que
n'est pas encore totalement sorti a des
conséquences sociales économiques de
cette crise les réformes telles qu'elles
étaient envisagées avant cette crise là
même s'il ya des aménagements sont à
portée c'est peut-être courir un peu
trop vite on en vient maintenant à à
l'assurance chômage donc audience
cruciale hier au conseil d'état si
l'institution tranche pour la suspension
le gouvernement devrait une nouvelle
fois revoir sa copie comme ça a été le
cas en 2010 neuf concernant vous formule
de calcul discriminatoire qu'est-ce qui
pourrait bloquer cette fois
devra revoir ses copies si effectivement
le conseil d'état juge de cette réforme
a suffisamment adaptées alors revoir sa
copie ce serait certainement l'occasion
je pense de reprendre le processus à son
début si on fait une rapide chronique de
ce qu'est cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage c'est en 2010 cette négociation
qui s'ouvre avec une lettre de cadrage
extrêmement strictes qui en conséquence
ne permet pas aux partenaires sociaux de
s'accorder sur un ajustement des
conditions de l'indemnisation on a vu le
brouhaha qui s'en est suivie après les
premières ordonnances les organisations
syndicales ont porté à la connaissance
du gouvernement certains cas qui en
conséquence aurait une révision des
conditions d'indemnisation extrêmement
strictes le gouvernement a en
conséquence adapter certaines des 10
certaines des dispositions jusqu'à ces
derniers jours
donc si le conseil d'état se prononce en
droit contre cette réforme là ce serait
l'opportunité me semble-t-il de tenter
de renouer le dialogue social
et s'il n'y a pas de suspension voire à
côté à côté de vous sur son les images
des images de manifestations s'il n'y a
pas de suspension comment s'attendre à
un mois de juillet avec beaucoup de
personnes dans la rue ou en tous les cas
à la rentrée de mathieu tendre mais vu
les commentaires que vous présentiez à
l'instant dans dans le reportage qui
précédait notre interview je pense qu il
faut effectivement enfin s'attendre à ce
que le diverses formes de manifestations
ce média se manifestent on ne peut pas
faire un show pense que les
organisations syndicales qui ont été
conduites à recourir au juge risque ou
peuvent ne pas en rester là pour
certaines d'entre elles au moins après
l'annoncé du décret correctif concernant
les arrêts maladie et maternité ainsi
que l'activité partielle les syndicats
se sont montrés plus confiants
l'unedic a retoqué ce correctif censé ne
plus pénaliser les chômeurs
connu des périodes de congés maladie de
maternité ou d'activité partielle
l'union a signalé le risque que le
correctif aille à l'encontre du code du
travail
est ce que vous pourriez nous expliquer
tout cela un peu plus précisément
certaines dé certains des ajustements
apportés par l'exécutif sur le site
première ordonnance conduisent à
recomposer dans des périodes non
travaillées l'équivalent d'un salaire
alors quelle est la légitimité et qu'
elle est là la constitutionnalité de ce
dispositif là allait effectivement mises
en cause où elle est critiquée par les
organisations syndicales qui sont
retournés vers l'unedic pour faire un
documenté cet aspect là bas donc on est
encore dans l'attenté de la décision
définitive du conseil qui donc est
attendu pour le début de la semaine
prochaine tous les commentaires sont
encore possibles mais je pense qu'il
nous faut attendre de voir en la
question des attendus du conseil du
conseil d'état pour pouvoir en tirer les
conclusions
merci chez monnier d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien directeur général adjoint de
l'unedic et membre du craps le cercle de
réflexion pour l'avenir de la protection
sociale